Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How are you?
Good. How about you?
I'm fine.
Thank you for asking.
How was your weekend?
I moved into a new house.
Really?
Did you finish unpacking?
Not yet.
I'm still working on it.
There must be a lot of things to do.
Yes.
In the morning, I vacuumed the carpet, took out the garbage, and polished the furniture.
Wow. You must be tired now.
Do you like your house?
Yes, it's just lovely.
I like its location, too.
That's good.
It's near a subway station.
How convenient!
Right.
It takes only ten minutes to get to a local park.
Wow! You can go jogging every morning!
That's right.
I'm starting from tomorrow morning.
That's good for your health.
That is a very nice place to live!
Thank you.
You should come over to my house someday.